- The guy bought $117
case of Pinot Grigio.
Right, so $10 a bottle
Pinot Grigio.
I go in his Twitter account
on this flight and all
he's tweeting about is following:
"Jay Cutler, I love you."
"Jay Cutler, you're the best."
"Jay Cutler, I'm mad at you."
For those who don't know
Jay Cutler is and was at the
time the quarterback
for the Chicago Bears.
He's talking about Jay Cutler,
Jay Cutler so I call my point
person back at the
store and I said,
"Look, I want you to go to eBay
"and I want you to buy him
a signed Jay Cutler jersey."
Which was like $350,
much more than the 8% profit
we made on the $111
case of Pinot Grigio
"and I want you to send a note
"in there and say thank
you for your order.
"Thanks for shopping Wine Library.'"
Great, I send it. And then three
and a half weeks go by and
nothing happens and I'm like
this son of a gun is really
not going to acknowledge
this random kindness.
We send out some other stuff
and then out of nowhere,
actually ironically,
I'm about to take stage
at a talk in Las Vegas
and I get a phone
call from Kristin.
She hasn't called me yet.
She works in the
Thank You Department.
She doesn't really need me.
She's only to call me about
these couple of things we sent
out and I pick up the phone
and I go "You got something?"
She goes "Kind of."
I go "Go ahead."
She goes, "I want to read
you the order we just got."
She reads off this order and how
many people here are in to wine?
Great, wow, amazing.
(laughter)
This person orders $4,800 worth
of high end red burgundy.
Coche Durie, Dugioalic
like real stuff for the
real nerds in here.
And here's what the
comment box said,
"Hey, my name is Craig.
I want you to know you guys
"sent my friend John
"a Chicago Bears jersey
"and he told me the story and
"that's how I found
out about you.
"P.S. You have great prices
on red burgundy.
" P.S.S. I'm a huge
Bruce Springsteen fan."
(laughter)
The punchline of that story
is you guys are curating events
and experiences
that really matter.
People, today more and
more as time goes on,
are sharing more and more
information about themselves.
We can cry about privacy but
everyday we prove with our
actions that we don't care.
And really, there's a much more
fascinating debate over that
which is that people
are inherently good.
That mainstream media just
talks about the small 1% of bad.
That's why we share our privacy.
Your ability to know
a lot more about the
people that are coming to
these events is far greater
than you may believe.
And that if you actually put in
the time to understand
who that is I promise
you this that if I came
to one of your events as
a top seller or executive
and I walked in to my
hotel room and instead
of a fruit basket or a
bottle of wine or a
nice welcome note that
there was a New York Jets hat
that would matter to me
because that would show
the thing that matters more
than anything which is
intent and effort.
(light music)